wo fängt es an zu regnen und bin ich in
verpackten rheinland oder 8 hallo mein
name ist khan herzlich willkommen leute
zu einem neuen video ich habe mir
nämlich gedacht ich starte ein micro
pletz play
ja das war wieder eine ganz tolle
begrüßung mal wieder hier von mir und
genau aus diesem grund befinden wir uns
hier heute schon in einer minecraft beta
1 punkt 8.1 welt wundervoll
das einchecken ich weiß heute ist
dienstag normalerweise kommt minecraft
auf meinem kanal am freitag allerdings
habe ich in letzter zeit wirklich so
viele hatten mich schief mitbekommen
günther jauch letzter zeit wirklich so
viele kommentare bekommen von wegen
lukas rate mal wieder mein klar macht
dass mal wieder damit bis zu groß
geworden hier bleibt lachen hier mache
ich machen let's play ihr seht schon ich
finde der minecraft beta 1 punkt 8.1 ich
habe nämlich vor einiger zeit ein video
hochgeladen wo ich die erste minecraft
version gezeigt habe hier können wir
quasi herum noch auch kummer ich kann
und da habe ich einfach mal in den
kommentaren gefragt ob ihr euch
vielleicht ein display in der beta
version vorstellen könntest und da sind
wirklich nahezu alle unter dem video
ausgelassen meinte cejka voll geil hast
du doch schon mal gemacht ich habe
früher mal so eine lost reihe gemacht
vor zwei jahren oder so wo ich so
beta-version gezockt habe früher war es
halt so dass wir dann in jedem video
eine version hoch gegangen sind das war
voll blöd nach hat zeit weil dann immer
die ganzen sachen angepasst werden
musste und häuser wurden dann nicht mehr
richtig komprimiert übernommen und so
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht die
starter einfach ein let's play in der
minecraft beta 1 von 8.1 und irgendwann
warum sich ihr holz blick wenig dumm
kommt irgendwann gehen wir dann
vielleicht meine version hoch und zocken
dann vielleicht mal eine andere version
und konvertieren dann die welt in den
neuen spielstand und so weiter und
sofort voll da brauche ich mich rundum
steine zu kriegen was kriege ich level
travel ihr müsst an dieser stelle wissen
dass ich nicht der beste minecraft
spieler bin und ich werde dieses letzte
wöchentlich hochladen
ich gebe euch jetzt einfach mal auch ein
paar infos zu dem let's play und zwar
wie so sind hier so fucking viele hühner
überall dieses let's play wird
wöchentlich auf meinem kann
willkommen also immer am dienstag wird
es quasi dann sonnenbad hiervon geben
weil ich will nicht dass das laser main
kanal einem welcher eigentlich derzeit
mehr so oft live ausgelegt bin und mir
das ein bisschen mehr spaß macht ich bin
sehr froh an deck zu haben dass sie auch
sprinten kann also ich weiss nicht in
der version die ich halt erst gezeugt
hatte wo viele meinten macht noch im
beta 10
spader konnte man halt nichts deswegen
ist dass ich schon so ein bisschen
interessante alles klar
ich bin dein mund kommt rein der vorne
sind noch ein bisschen zuckerrohr sachen
und ja also weitere infos zum display
immer die stadt wird dann auf meinem
kanal so eine folge von diesem letzten
gekommen am freitag kommt dann kein
minecraft mehr sondern dann irgendwas
anderes
ja allerdings habe ich hier mit jetzt
halt alles miteinander verbunden was ich
eigentlich gewünscht wurde viele leute
sollten dass ich ein längerfristiges
player von viele leute nicht mehr
minecraft gewünscht deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht zu machen längerfristige am
eingang der höhle wenn viele leute sagen
dann baut sich noch mal runter aber ich
springe einfach rein
ich habe keine fackeln das ist sehr gut
luca wer hat mir erlaubt sich dieses
spiel zu kaufen
komme ich überhaupt raus ich habe mir
jetzt hier einfach mal so einen weg raus
gebaut und wir merken uns diese höhle
und gehen da später rein und ist auch in
eppstein jugendlichen im ort stellen ich
halt immer nur mit wie alle anderen
youtuber irgendwelche krassen l'espace
machen mit krassen webex und ich werde
einfach in der beta zocken ist auch
vielleicht cool oder so bin ich doch
gespannt gerade der heute aber diese
anderen sounds noch raus mag diese summe
eigentlich gar nicht so krass also das
ist eigentlich nur so ja ich hasse
dieses thema eigentlich eine ewigkeit
später
das sieht doch schon mal viel cooler aus
hier das wär halt echt geil wenn wir uns
dann irgendwie unser haus irgendwie hier
in die mitte vom see bauen würden und
dann haben wir quasi da vorne sodass
komische sumpfgebiet da vorne ehe man
normale mein gott ist das was ist das
für ein berg vor allem respekt kleiner
see da unten aber lücke dilsberg magath
aber noch viel krassere berge alter
schwede wo sie mir denn hier gelandet
kacke die sonne geht unter gut ich habe
halt nicht mein bett gerade da unten
sind schafe mit denen könnte ich mir
theoretisch [ __ ] my life doch schon
zombies ich kann ja aber gerade nicht
runter springen weil in das becken
dahinten komme ich nicht da unten sind
zombies und ich muss aber wo fängt es an
zu regnen und bin ich in kontakt treten
land dollar ab da bin ich extra den
ganzen weg hier hoch geschieht für
diesen scheiß berg um dann zu sehen dass
die ganzen schafe die ich für meine
betten brauche unten sind
hallo ich komm runter gewartet wir
müssen dann halt echt mal gucken wir uns
irgendwie da vorne ihr seht
wahrscheinlichkeit gar nichts weil der
regen so kacke ist ein paar sekunden
später oh mein gott oh mein gott
ok ok viereinhalb herzen wir haben hier
schafe ich musste mein gott noch mehr
als skelette ok ok people can you please
stay away
ich hoffe es ist möglich dass ich jetzt
gegen wie mein bett hin platziere und
mich einfach nur hierhin schlafende ok
rating buy ein
wo bist du doch da der kripo fakt mich
ein bisschen ab ich weiß nicht ob ich
gegen den scharfen georg yoga ist ja
irgendwie schneller geworden oder so den
krippe haben wir getötet darum muss erst
mal schön die erfahrungen hier wir
könnten uns auch ein bisschen weichsel
damit wir nachher weiß essen können also
wir haben alle da oben den berg und wir
haben halt dann berg ich weiß halt nur
nicht wo ich mich jetzt hin bauen soll
alter wollte mich denn verarschen
wieso ist denn da direkt wieder hey ich
weiß nicht wo ich mich in bonn soll also
ich wäre dafür dass wir uns erst mal
hierhin bauen und hier einfach bach
warum ist denn dann zombie ich wäre
dafür wir bauen uns erstmal da auf dem
berg drauf und setzen uns da ein paar
kisten hin so dass wir dann erst mal
eine kleine base haben ach guck mal das
ist ein höhleneingang hier und jetzt
haben wir auf jeden fall auch schon ein
bisschen kohle ich glaube der zombies
hier irgendwo oben drüber über uns oder
das hier war der durchgang wo gerade der
zombie stand ich weiß allerdings nicht
wo der jetzt gerade ist also unten sind
auf jeden fall für aber das ist sehr
schön hier auch gönnt sich halt hier
wirklich perfekt hinbauen irgendwie
zwischen so ein paar brücken und in der
mitte wo nicht dann das werden wir
machen
an dieser stelle würde ich dann auch das
video beende meine damen und herren wir
stehen wir jetzt hier an dem platz wo
ich dann auch in der nächsten folge mein
hauptquartier hinschlagen werden denn
euch das video gefallen hat wirklich
meine bewertung freund spam mir die
kompletten kommentare zu mit tipps
sachen die ich bauen soll vielleicht
fragen die ich dann beantworte
kommentare alles haut einfach alles in
die kommentare was irgendwie mit
minecraft zu tun hat oder irgendwie ihr
mir weiter helfen wollt was ich bauen
soll worauf ich achten soll et cetera pp
und dann sehen wir uns nächsten dienstag
in einer weiteren folge von diesem
letztlich wieder bis dahin haut rein und
tschüss